he's the question we're getting set up
with okay now here's the thing right you
know how we did talk before about
one-step and two-step equations okay
he's the theme addition subtraction
multiplication division that's basically
basically all the tools they're using to
make these equations okay but there are
so many combinations of ways to put
these together right that thinking about
these categories stops being useful you
look at this and you're like what are
exactly though once they're for two
steps that you do so what I'm going to
do instead of saying look here's the
same thing you do over and over again
I'm going to try to give you a general
set of strategies that will always be
useful no matter what you've got for
these kinds of equations and it might be
three or four or more steps but it
doesn't matter how many steps the
strategies will still apply okay
so we have tried to solve this thing
right that's the question
so this in other words we want to find a
value of x that work what the key that
will unlock the equation to make
actually correct okay so how we're gonna
do this here's my general strategy
number one okay so maybe you want to
write this off on the side and then
we're going to do it here okay the first
strategy is collect like terms
okay now we looked at collecting like
terms before in algebra without
equations in the picture okay
so for instance let me just give you an
example off the side you don't have to
write it down but look up at it so you
can follow it with me you might have
gotten something like this okay there
you go
this is not an equation it's not an
equation why not no equal sign so it's
just an expression right but I can still
simplify it like it's still super flat
okay the way that I would do it and
we've seen this before you would collect
like terms you're looking for these
things that are kind of similar to each
other right now I can see a couple of
pairs of different things that I can
combine together freezes it will any
takers first thing yeah there is good
I've got six amps here right and if you
have another color catalog that will
help you as you go through this right
I've got six of them here and I've got
three here right so I'm gonna have nine
so I'm gonna write that as 9 and I've
collected those terms cool then I've got
the other terms they don't have any
layers of them so we call them is is
just that the constants okay these
numbers so there's negative seven and
two plus two and you go to watch out for
the sign it's a bit sneaky right
negative seven plus two if I write them
off on the side negative seven plus two
what's that equal this is the number
line here right there's zero and they're
being negative one two three four five
six seven
because negatives is plus two beads go
to over and that's why as you said
negative five so I'm gonna take these
two terms and I collect them and that's
what I've got
yep
ah right okay
so the question about like what makes a
like term what makes like terms away
right is more about these things here
what's attached to the number less than
whether it's positive or negative
okay we can mix together positive and
negative numbers in there okay right but
you can't mix together ABS in twos right
they don't gel together 3 and +2 there's
no way you can supply it it's just 3 and
+2 so that's why you've got these two
they're like terms right and then you
got these two electives okay good now
we're gonna do a very silly thing over
here the last question I got this was
how do I know whether this is positive 9
and negative 9 it's positive the reason
why is because up here right you look at
besides the original numbers now I know
there's no sign of this one but it's cuz
that's cuz hiding right if I I said you
know I've got I've got five shirts right
I don't you don't think oh is it
positive or negative if you just see a
number you assume it's positive right so
that positive six positive three that's
why it's positive no there's no
negatives and all they come into play
there okay when there are then we can
account for it and that's why that's a
negative 5 minus 5 all right good good
question does anyone have any other
questions on that does it make sense
okay we're gonna do much the same kind
of thing here but the equals sign
changes things very very slightly okay
what are we working toward what's what's
your final wine what's it going to look
like it's gonna have X equals R then a
number right I suppose you could say
like some sub number equals x but that's
a bit of an awkward way to write it
okay so when you have a look here right
I'm not just gonna click my toes
wherever I like
I want the x's to be on the left hand
side okay so watch
where are the x-terms there's a pair of
right there's a 6x and a 5x I'm gonna
circle them and I encourage you to do
the same there are just two okay that's
it they're not that hard to spot but
sometimes there will be wanted you there
three or four or five and you have to
make sure you don't miss any of them
that's the point of collecting them okay
now I want them to be on this side and
not this side right so another way of
saying that is I want to get rid of all
of the X's on this side and push them
over this side so what should I do to
both sides of the equation to get rid of
all of the X's on this side okay all
right
where aren't your you're getting off to
something your pointer here okay it is
weird having something over here and
something over here interact you with
each other I'm going to show you how
they will okay at the moment here's my
goal and I'll show you how to work I
want to get rid of all the x over here
no no same question same question okay
here's my god I want to collect like
terms I want all the X's not to be
spread out across both sides
I like them all on this side not on this
side so here's what I'll do
remember when it's an equation right
you've got to do the same thing to both
sides all the time so it stays equal
right if you had 2x equals 10 what would
you do both sides you would divide by 2
what are you still working yes right
okay if I had this okay what would I do
to both sides I would take away one that
would give me X and 9 so these are okay
and these are okay now what I want to do
here is I want to get rid of all these
X's over here there's five of them right
so what I'm gonna do is I'll take away
5x do you say that's gonna get rid of
all of these X's on this side but of
course as we've just demonstrated you
can't just take something away from one
side and not the other so I have to take
5x away from this side also
okay can you see what I've done is that
a right this second line all it is is
this part I got from the first line and
then I subtracted 5 X from the left and
the right it's still balanced down right
still balanced still balanced still
balanced okay all right now why did I
choose to subtract 5x it was because I
would get rid of all the excess of this
side what's gonna happen to the
right-hand side by the X cancels with
this so you just end up with 7 okay now
what's gonna happen on the left-hand
side well the X is not gonna cancel
because it's not the same number I'm
gonna collect like terms over here I've
got 6x minus 5x yep
so how many X's we'll have that so just
the 106 - yeah I collected the X's over
there but they still have 5 X plus 5 you
see what I did so again let me try and
highlight for you
this 6x and this minus 5x they came
together I collected them and they just
became one there that plus 5 from here
just hangs on all right now I'm always
done right this this is the kind of
equation which we saw like early in the
exercise I suppose you would call this a
one-step equation wouldn't you what do I
do what I do to both sides to get X by
itself I take away 5 ok now the great
thing about this remember I keep saying
the great theme of equations is that if
you get an answer at the end there's
never any doubt as to whether you got it
right I should be able to chuck it up
here and see what happens and it should
work
right you don't have to do this but just
for the sake of it let's just make sure
that we got it right what's the
left-hand side going to be equal to
it's going to be 6 times X which is 2
+5 what 6 times to 12 plus 5 is 17 okay
what do I get on the right-hand side I
get well let's just make sure I got 5
times X which is 2 plus 7 which is 10
plus 7 which is 17 it works and so
that's how you could know x equals 2 is
correct
okay so I didn't write down first we
collected like terms okay and then what
we did was we simplified when you
simplify after that what you get down to
is something which are very familiar you
know how to solve these ok so it's
taking a problem which is more
complicated and sort of working at it
and chippy away until it's something
that you do know how to do with okay
collecting like terms is simplifying no
matter how many steps your equation will
be is always going to be a helpful pair
of strategies that you can use to get to
your answer okay